- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
non-commercial use only.
Check out our YouTube original channel,
UCTV Prime at youtube.com/uctvprime.
Subscribe today to get
new programs every week.
(gentle music)
- As you know from the program
and just from general knowledge,
these lectures were established in 1976
by colleagues, joined by friends, family,
and students to commemorate
the contributions
and their continuing
influences and transformations
of Carl Sauer,
who was perhaps one of the, or certainly,
is one of the most influential geographers
of the 20th century.
His books, his works,
are veritably crossed
and trans-disciplinary,
there are many concepts and approaches
that Sauer pioneered and/or championed
that scholars use today,
often without realizing their
origin and their history.
Sauer was a professor of geography
here at Berkeley from 1923 to 1957.
And he was an emeritus professor
until his death in 1975.
This was the formative time
of what became a distinctly
Berkeley cultural geography.
And you would not be surprised to learn
that being a contemporary here,
with the anthropologist Alfred Kroeber,
there were discussions and debates
between the two and their students,
both leaving a legacy of
promise and challenges
to the understanding of human cultures,
their landscapes, and their histories.
We are honored that
members of the Sauer family
are here with us today for
the 21st Sauer Memorial Lecture,
and we are grateful to them
for their continuing
support of the endowment.
Today I am really pleased to introduce
our 21st Sauer Lecturer,
Professor Marie Price,
of the George Washington University,
where she is recently Chair of
the Department of Geography.
As you will understand from her lecture,
she is also a professor
of international affairs
and has served as director
of the Latin American Studies
for the Elliot School of
International Affairs.
She is frequently on call for the press
and many organizations,
and if you go onto Google,
you can find some interviews with her.
Given her expertise on such crucial topics
for today's world as immigration,
this is something of a homecoming,
if you will, for Marie.
She is a Californian.
She is a Berkeley graduate.
Having earned her bachelor's degree here
in the Department of Geography before
attending Syracuse University from where
she received her PhD in 1991.
She's had extensive field experience
researching urban immigration,
migration, and development
in Latin America.
She's surveyed immigration from Bolivia,
investigated migration and
coffee cultivation in Venezuela,
and gathered data and
conducted field research
on global cities and immigrants.
Her articles have been published
in such journals as the Annals of
the Association of the
American Geographers,
the Geographical Review,
the Journal of Historical
Geography, Urban Geography,
International Journal of
Urban and Regional Research,
Studies in Comparative
International Development and Focus.
Her books include a co-edited book,
Migrants to the Metropolis:
the Rise of Immigrant
Gateway Cities in 2008,
with Lisa Benton-Short,
and up now to the 5th
edition of the textbook,
Diversity Amid Globalization:
World Regions, Environment,
and Development,
co-authored with Les
Rowntree, Martin Lewis,
and William Wyckoff,
who are all here today
to celebrate their co-author.
Price is a member and very active member
of several of the key
professional associations,
including the American
Geographical Society,
the Association of American Geographers,
the Institute of Current World Affairs,
the Latin American Studies Association,
and the Society of Women Geographers.
She's been awarded numerous honors
for her extensive work in the field.
In 2010, the Conference of
Latin Americanist Geographers
awarded her the Preston E. James
Eminent Latin Americanist career award.
She received the 2005 Trachtenberg Prize
for Teaching from GW, George
Washington University,
and her article that she
co-authored with Catherine Cooper:
Competing Visions, Shifting Boundaries:
The Construction of Latin
America as a World Region
was honored as a best current,
concant article of 2008
in the Journal of Geography
by the National Council
for Geographic Education.
We are therefore more than pleased
to be able to welcome
Marie back to Berkeley,
where she will give
her presentation today.
As you can see,
Diffusion, Deflection, and Diversity:
A geographic perspective on
contemporary immigration.
Marie.
(audience applauds)
- Well, it's a great privilege to be here,
and to see so many
familiar faces and friends.
I was thinking when I agreed to do this
that the Sauer Lecture changed my life.
In 1983, I was an undergraduate,
and I've only attended one Sauer lecture.
It was given by D.W. Meinig,
and after the event,
as would be Betty Parson's tradition,
she invited everybody
up to eat at her house,
it was a big crowd.
And she asked me if I'd help.
I was an undergraduate, I said yes.
(audience laughs)
The end of the dinner, everyone's served,
and there's one seat left at the table,
and it's next to D.W. Meinig,
and I sat next to him.
And next thing you know,
I was headed to Syracuse
University to get a PhD.
(audience laughs)
So be forewarned,
this lecture could change your life.
(audience laughs)
Professor Conkey invited
me to give this lecture
and I was honored and both taken aback.
My work is very unlike Carl Sauer's,
surely there were others that would be
more appropriate to give this talk.
I write about contemporary immigration,
and rely on large datasets
from censuses and government agencies
to examine the demographic, cultural,
and political consequences
of labor migration.
Sauer was interested in plant
and animal domestication
by historical and prehistorical peoples,
undergoing processes that are largely
non-recurrent and concerning spans of time
beyond the short runs
available to enumeration.
Sauer's brand of cultural history
focused on human environmental interaction
and the place of humans in nature,
whereas I'm interested in
human patterns of settlement
and social inclusion and exclusion
in increasingly diverse cities.
As different as my empirical
focus is from Carl Sauer's,
the Berkeley school tradition
of cultural geography
has always inspired me as a fertile
and diverse body of scholarship
focused upon field work and
long-term landscape change,
especially in Latin America.
This is a illustration
done by a Bolivian artist,
Antonio Sotomayor, of
Sauer in the field, 1932.
And you know it's Sauer
because he has a pipe in his mouth,
he's in the cot in the front.
(audience laughs)
And insistence on field experience
was the rule in Sauer's day,
and I'm happy to see it's very much
alive today among Berkeley geographers.
The value of going to places,
observing forms and patterns,
talking with people,
digging into archives,
mapping results cannot be underestimated.
Interestingly, since
many immigration scholars
base their research on
statistical analysis
and large datasets,
having a field component
in my immigration research often leads to
different lines of argument
and interpretation.
Secondly, Sauer stressed the importance
of following particular themes or topics
rather than insisting
on regional expertise
for its own sake.
Field work in Latin America led to
Sauer's interest in agricultural
origins and dispersals
as well as native peoples.
But ultimately, the
topic demanded research
well beyond the boundaries
of Latin America.
Similarly, I was trained
as a Latin Americanist
at Syracuse University,
but due to the global reach
of international migrants,
my research has stretched
into new localities,
such as the streets of Barcelona, Dubai,
or Washington DC, as well
as into new literatures.
Sauer insisted that geographers make
value judgements in their
writings and actions,
and for Sauer,
these judgements reflected
his serious concern
about environmental degradation,
especially the threat that modernity posed
for traditional rural peoples.
Sauer was not an overt activist
but he's thought to
engage a broad audience
and share his deeply held conviction for
the necessity of sustainable livelihoods.
Over 70 years ago,
he published a subtly subversive book
for American schoolchildren,
Man in Nature:
America before the days of the white man.
Granted, it's not a gender neutral title,
but it was handsomely illustrated
by a Bolivian artist, Antonio Sotomayor.
And it was a book meant to teach
American children about Amer Indian life
prior to European contact
that was way ahead of its time.
Sadly its message did not penetrate
US school curriculum in the 1930s
but it demonstrates a conscious effort
at outreach and engagement that continued
throughout his lifetime.
As an immigration scholar,
my outreach has been
through policy engagement,
working with immigrant groups
and creating tools that
local jurisdictions
can use to facilitate immigrant inclusion,
a project I just finished with UNESCO.
The value judgment I bring to my research
is that immigrant inclusion
is important but difficult,
and does not naturally happen,
because racially, linguistically,
ethnically distinct immigrants force
a reexamination of self
and collective identity
that can be difficult for
native and foreign-born alike.
Yet ultimately, inclusion is essential
in our increasingly diverse
and immigrant-dependent societies.
Or as political scientist
Robert Putnam reminds us,
the central challenge for
modern, diversifying societies
is to create a new and
broader sense of we.
I was fortunate to be an undergraduate
at Berkeley in the early 1980s,
when practitioners of the Berkeley School
of Cultural Geography
were still an active force
in the Department of Geography.
And when I teach geographic thought
to seniors in my department,
they all read works by Carl Sauer.
Most recently, we discussed the essay,
the Seminar as Exploration,
which is currently included
in William Denevan's
newly edited collection called,
Carl Sauer on culture and landscapes.
And as Dr. Conkey said,
you cannot ignore Carl Sauer
when you're talking about 20th century
North American geography.
My human bridge to the tradition
was the incomparable Dr. James Parsons,
a student of Sauer's
and noted Latin Americanist
in his own right.
Parsons was a mentor and friend
from my undergraduate days at Cal
until his death in 1997.
Jim always referred to
Carl Sauer as Mr. Sauer.
A deferential stance towards the man
and his work that frankly
seemed out of place
with the rough and tumble world
of Berkeley academic discourse.
What was it about the
man and his scholarship
that seemed beyond reproach?
For some geographers in the department,
I always suspected that this deference
was annoying and even
downright perturbing.
Like Sauer, most Berkeley scholars
are eager to chart their own course.
And by the 1980s, critical
social theory, and later,
political ecology were
the roads that beckoned.
Traditional cultural
geography a la Berkeley
was too much cumbersome baggage,
best to cast aside.
I believe that a tremendous opportunity
was lost by this rejection.
Rather than build connections
with an intellectual tradition
that has inspired multiple generations
of American and Latin
American geographers,
the preferred course was
an active disassociation
from a rich academic inheritance
that any other department
wouldn't have erased.
So in today's talk,
I hope to demonstrate
how two traditional Sauerian concepts,
cultural diffusion and cultural landscape,
have been relevant in my
research on immigration.
I will draw upon a decade of field work
in the Americas,
especially Washington DC
and Cochabamba, Bolivia,
to demonstrate how immigration creates
new patterns of diffusion
and ruptures in the landscape
that must be acknowledged
in order for more inclusive
and diverse communities.
So let us turn now to
the topic of immigration.
Immigration has always captured
my geographic imagination.
The literature on immigration is immense
and scholars from many disciplines
contribute to it.
Ironically, given the popular
and scholarly interest in immigration,
very few people actually
leave their country of birth
for residence abroad.
According to the United Nations,
the migrant stock figure
is 214 million people,
or 3.1% of the world's 7 billion people.
Of course, this figure does not capture
all international
migration so it's important
to consider this number
as a demographic floor
and not a ceiling.
This figure shows the steady upward trend
in the estimates of global migrant stock.
Here the absolute numbers
warrant attention.
In 1960, the world's migrant stock
was about 80 million,
and a large portion of those numbers
came from the partitioning of India
along with traditional
countries of settlement,
the US, Canada, Argentina, and Australia.
Today the number exceeds 214 million,
which if grouped together in one state,
would be the fifth largest
country in the world,
wedged in between Indonesia and Brazil.
Despite the absolute growth of immigrants,
for 50 years,
the world's migrant stock has ranged
between 2.1 or 3.1% of
the world's population.
So why is immigration a big deal
if so few people leave?
The answer is uneven
geographic distribution.
When shifting level to the nation state,
where immigrants settle
is extremely uneven,
both in terms of absolute numbers
and proportion of the total population.
It's no surprise to anyone in this room
that the United States has the largest
foreign-born population around 40 million,
which is more than three
times larger than Russia,
which has the second largest
foreign-born population,
followed by Germany, Saudi
Arabia, Canada, and France.
A more interesting list of
immigration destinations
shows that states where migrants make up
the largest proportion
of the total population.
Here the Gulf States stand out,
with Qatar topping the list
at a whopping 87% foreign-born,
followed by the UAE at 70%,
and Kuwait at 69%.
Migrants to these countries
come from other Arab states,
but also large numbers are
from South and Southeast Asia.
A running joke amongst immigrants in Dubai
is that it's the best run Indian city
in the world.
(audience laughs)
Two cities on this list,
Singapore, a city state
that relies heavily
upon immigrants from neighboring Malaysia
but also from East and Southeast Asia,
and Hong Kong, which for
administrative purposes,
is still treated as a
demographically distinct
entity from the PRC,
although not surprisingly,
the majority of Hong Kong's immigrants
come from mainland China.
By comparison, the US,
which is not on this list,
only has 12.5% of its
population foreign-born.
The uneven geography
of immigrant settlement
is more stunning when you shift
to the scale of analysis
to metropolitan areas.
In research that Lisa Benton-Short and I
conducted on immigrant gateways,
we found that 19 metropolitan areas
that had over one million
foreign-born residents
accounted for nearly one in five
of the world's immigrants in 2005.
This map is dynamic and changing.
Cities such as Doha and
Madrid may soon be added.
Buenos Aires fell off the list
but may be back on when
the census is completed.
Also there's emerging
data on the foreign-born
in Chinese cities, especially Shanghai,
and these global immigrant destinations
of foreign-born can be one quarter or more
of the total population,
a point that's underscored
by this next figure,
which shows a list of cities
followed by the percentage
foreign-born in red,
and then the percentage
of the country's foreign-born in blue.
So for example, Toronto, which
is over 45% foreign-born,
is, where is the country of Canada,
it's a little bit about 20% foreign-born.
Mapping the world's urban
immigrant destinations
is challenging because no agency
collects and distributes
urban immigrant data.
But this figure shows metropolitan areas,
with work I've done with
my colleagues at GW,
that have at least 100,000
foreign-born in purple,
those with 250,000 foreign-born in green,
and over a million in red.
Europe, the region of the
world with the most immigrants,
and North America
dominate this world view.
Yet, Southwest Asia has
many important destinations
and there's some significant shifts
occurring in East Asia
with more immigrants
flowing into cities in
Japan, Korea, and China.
Unfortunately, serious data gaps result
in under-representation
of immigrant movements
in Sub-Saharan Africa,
which we know are significant
but we just don't have data on,
as well as for India and China,
although China's story is really much more
of an internal migration.
But on this map,
there are over 140 metropolitan areas
that account for about
70 million immigrants.
And each of these dots represents cities
that are experiencing
demographic, cultural,
and economic change due to immigration.
So let me turn to the first
concept of cultural diffusion.
Large scale contemporary immigration,
especially the cities,
creates new pathways of cultural diffusion
that are both exhilarating
and intimidating
to localities and livelihoods.
The agents of cultural diffusion
are immigrants themselves,
especially when they arrive
in large numbers as adults
and bring with them
distinct cultural practices,
languages, religions, food preferences,
identities, and taste.
Obviously, culture is complex,
and cannot be reduced to national origins.
But country of origin is
not a bad proxy measure
for culture and it gives us some data
to work with when trying to understand
global and metropolitan level change.
To appreciate this shifting
cultural complexity,
we need a new reality TV show.
Call it Wheaton 20906.
Anyone know Wheaton?
There's Wheaton right there.
Imagine a suburb that
was 97% white in 1970.
But in the decades of the 90s,
received new immigrants
from 131 countries.
This was not the only zip
code in the Washington area
that received a sudden and
diverse flux of immigrants.
Metropolitan Washington is still
a relatively new immigrant gateway,
compared to San Francisco at least.
But the foreign-born poured in,
in the 1980s and 90s,
and now make up about 20%
of the metropolitan area's population.
There are varying ways
that we can visualize this
that are suggestive of both demographic
and sociocultural change.
So this map here is
showing just the suburbs
of Washington and the codings,
the pale yellow is less
than 9% foreign-born,
the darker yellow 10 or more,
and the orange 20%.
This is what the pattern looked like in
from the 1980 census.
This is the 1990 census.
And this is the 2000 census.
And as an editorial aside,
the US census, note, did not ask in 2010,
foreign-born status,
so it would be really
interesting to know that
but we will not,
though you can kinda
dig through the ACS data
and try and piece it together.
But there are other ways
to think about this change.
I rather like this map.
I couldn't show all
the different countries
cuz the map would look
like a plate of spaghetti,
but by regions you see that Washington
does get a very diverse flow of immigrants
from South America, Central America,
East Asia, Southeast
Asia, Africa, and Europe.
Or the ever popular pie chart.
One of the things that makes
Washington a bit different
is the mix of its immigrants.
The largest group is Salvadoran,
followed by India, Korea, Mexico, Vietnam,
Philippines, China, Guatemala,
Bolivia, and Ethiopia.
In major immigrant destinations,
such as Washington,
San Francisco, Chicago,
or New York, social scientists
are still struggling
to understand what does culture mean
in such diverse settings.
What kind of society will form
and how do we visualize it?
Anthropologist Arjun Appadurai summarizes
the problem in his work,
Modernity at Large.
As groups migrate,
regroup in new locations,
reconstruct their histories,
and reconfigure their ethnic projects,
the ethno in ethnography
takes on a slippery,
non-localized quality
to which the descriptive
practice of anthropology
will have to respond.
Like anthropologists,
many cultural geographers
usually associate culture with territory,
yet it is the non-localized,
or reterritorialized
experience of culture,
in part brought about by
complex migratory streams,
that is unsettling and unexpected.
This unsettling experience happened to me
at a PTA meeting at my son's middle school
several years ago.
Before it began, an announcement was made
that the proceedings
would be simultaneously
translated into Spanish, not unusual,
and Mongolian, unusual.
(audience laughs)
I later found out that through
the US Diversity Visa Program,
a sudden influx of Mongolian families
had arrived in the early 2000s
and settled in Arlington County,
hence the unsettling need
for Mongolian translation.
There is an uneasiness
when our assumptions
about the cultural map of a place
do not conform to our experience.
And in places that undergo
rapid demographic change
due to immigration,
the sense of cultural uncertainty
is shared by native-born
and foreign-born alike.
Imagine again what it must be like
to live in a zip code with
neighbors from 130 countries.
Given the cultural ambiguity,
it's not surprising that immigrant groups
seek refuge among co-ethnics to affirm
a sense of identity.
One Bolivian immigrant in
metropolitan Washington
explained the need to do folkloric dance
and such as a refuge.
It's very difficult to come
to a country like this,
it's so big, that is a monster.
It's a monster to us because
it's so big and diverse.
Then this is the reason why
we continue folkloric dancing.
It's a cultural refuge.
We like to dance.
We like the music.
It's a cultural refuge to maintain life
and stay connected with Bolivia.
When I dance and dance, I return.
But this cultural practice
of folkloric dance
on a fall afternoon
occurred in a suburban park,
where children and parents
from other countries
also viewed the spectacle with curiosity,
and perhaps some empathy
that this was a symbolic
act of return or at least
an expression of identity
in a multicultural setting.
Yet the feeling of
displacement also happens
among the native-born.
It's them, the immigrants
who've made us into racists,
remarked a Swedish teen
quoted in geographer
Allen Pred's remarkable
and unblinking analysis
of immigrant exclusion and segregation.
Even in Sweden, racism, racialized spaces,
and popular geographical imagination
describes the intolerance
and spatial segregation
experienced by racially
distinct immigrants.
In a formerly homogeneous country,
long recognized for its
progressive policies
of social tolerance,
as the title suggests,
seemingly tolerant
places can suddenly shift
when immigration is
questioned or rejected.
In fact, the certainty of
anti-immigrant backlash
is perhaps the one law of immigration
that we can count on.
Demetri Papademetriou, a founder
of the Migration Policy Institute,
contends that when support
for immigration collapses,
which historically speaking,
occurs with pendulum-like regularity,
the duration and depth
of a society's engagement
with the process does not seem
too inoculated against
excessive reactions.
Excessive reactions
happen no matter the size,
composition, or contributions
of an immigrant population.
So if you accept the
premise that immigration
results in cultural diffusion
and in some cases,
hyper-diverse localities form,
then how do localities
and the people in them,
react to these changes?
In general, there are
three spatial strategies
that emerge as immigrant newcomers settle
in cities and localities.
They're loosely grouped in
concentration segregation strategies,
deflection strategies, or an
integration diversity approach.
How intentional these strategies are
can vary over time and with
distinct immigrant groups
and local governance.
Also, in any one locality,
each of these patterns may be evident.
So I'll begin with concentration
and, or segregation.
It's irresistible for geographers
to map immigrant residential patterns.
Geocoded census data invites others
to take such spatial patterning seriously.
Patterns of immigrant clusters, however,
do not get at the processes
by which they form.
The drivers may be
economic housing policies,
network driven, or
blatantly discriminatory.
In the US, the formal restriction
of immigrant settlement
to particular areas
of a city is not legal,
but that does not stop informal networks
and structural forces from directing
certain immigrants to
reside in particular areas.
One of the interesting
debates in immigration policy,
especially refugee policy,
is should clustering be
encouraged or discouraged.
Or how much does racial
or ethnic segregation
inhibit social and economic
integration in society.
Evidence shows that
concentrated immigrant areas
are often poorer, less educated,
and linguistically isolated.
Yet others contend that
in a democratic society,
if immigrants self select to cluster
among co-ethnics then it's
their choice and their right.
For immigrant groups small and large,
highly skilled or less skilled,
there are clear advantages in clustering.
Geographer Wei Lee writes about ethnoburbs
as a suburban cultural
and commercial landscape
that form to meet immigrant needs
and maintain transnational linkages.
This does not mean that
compact neighborhoods emerge
of a single ethnic group,
such as Little Italy,
but if co-ethnics settle
relatively near each other,
then an ethnic economy
emerges with small businesses,
such as restaurants,
travel agencies, groceries,
money sending services that serve
the particular needs of immigrants.
In this map, Bolivians in Washington
show some patterns of concentration
especially in Northern Virginia.
But what's interesting is
when I was in a focus group
with business entrepreneurs
who were Bolivian,
didn't show them this map,
I showed them a map of Washington
and asked them where did they think
the best place for business
opportunities were,
and it pretty neatly conformed
with where the Bolivians resided.
The second strategy, called deflection.
Deflection is an exclusionary practice
that happens regularly
and may also explain why immigrants
leave one area of a city for another
or cluster in particular areas.
Deflection happens
according to sociologist
Sibon Light, when zoning ordinances,
anti-loitering laws,
industrial regulations,
often created for other purposes,
are enforced to push out
or redirect poor immigrants
away from particular cities or suburbs.
Light describes it as a four step process
of absorption, saturation,
intolerance, and later deflection,
which pushes migrants around US cities.
So in metropolitan Washington,
there've been three major
deflection strategies,
which I've had the
opportunity to view up close.
Zoning against excessive occupancy,
regulation of day labor
sites and 287G agreements.
Interviewing local
officials and town planners,
going to town meetings,
conducting focus groups
at day labor sites,
provided insight in
how deflection happens.
Most local jurisdictions
have occupancy limits
based on housing type that are in place
for public protection and safety.
But enforcement of these
codes vary tremendously.
Typically, if the neighbor is unhappy with
the number of cars in a
nearby private residence,
he or she can report
excessive occupancy violations
to the town and they are
obliged to investigate it.
Immigrants often feel targeted by this,
saying that they have larger households
and extended families.
At one point, the town
of Manassas, Virginia,
which had experienced a dramatic surge
in Hispanic population, tried
to legally define family.
And when they couldn't do that,
they took the unusual approach
of passing a local ordinance that made it
illegal to sleep in any
other room but a bedroom.
(audience laughs)
Not surprisingly, the law
was contested and repealed.
Day labor sites can be
informally tolerated
by communities, formally
organized by them,
or aggressively prosecuted.
The town of Herndon,
Virgina, erupted in 2005,
as it struggled to resolve
the day labor issue.
And here's some day laborers gathered,
actually they're mostly sending money
back home in this photo.
Herndon straddles the border of Fairfax
and Loudoun counties near Dulles Airport.
Herndon's immigration population grew
in neighborhoods with older,
less expensive apartments
and single family homes.
But it was a concentrated gathering,
sometimes 200 or more, of
Hispanic men near a 7-11,
waiting for work that
drew the ire of residents.
A coalition of religious
groups and a progressive mayor
created a formal day labor site
in a former police station
at the edge of town
where the men could gather.
Employers and employees could register,
and English language classes
were taught by volunteers,
and interestingly enough,
I found a geographer who
was running this site.
Yet a race for mayor in
2006 led to a denouncing
of public money going to non-citizens.
A new mayor was elected,
the facility was eventually closed.
Loitering laws were aggressively enforced,
and the day laborers began to dissipate,
many moving to other more tolerant areas
in the metropolitan area.
Yet the most politically
contentious strategy
has been the adoption of 287G agreements,
where local law enforcement officers
are trained to act as immigration
enforcement officials.
And interestingly enough,
Herndon was one of the
first towns to adopt
the 287G agreement, which was considerably
more costly than maintaining
the day labor site.
But it was Prince William's County
decision to adopt the 287G,
led by an,
an ambitious chair of the
county board of supervisors,
Corey Stewart, that led to a ugly chapter
in immigration deflection processes.
Among Latinos, Prince
William County had been
a popular destination with good schools
and affordable housing,
but suddenly it became tierra prohibida.
A year and a half into the program,
when enrollment in ESL
programs showed declines,
Corey Steward declared victory.
Yet the stigma against
Prince William County's
anti-illegal immigrant
approach manifested itself
in stunning devaluation of home prices,
and a dramatic drop in small businesses,
so much that the Chamber of Commerce
asked that they stop
enforcing the policies.
The county was hurt much
more by the economic
recession in 2008 and nine
than comparable outer jurisdictions.
Robert Putnam's 2007 large scale study
documenting greater erosion
of social capital or trust
in more ethnically diverse settings
is a relevant albeit controversial study.
He warns, in the short to medium term,
immigration and ethnic diversity challenge
social solidarity and
inhibit social capital,
or in the vernacular, diversity
at least in the short run,
brings out the turtle in all of us.
Yet there are scholars that highlight
the diversity advantage
such as Richard Florida's
the Rise of the Creative Class,
or AnnaLee Saxenian's the New Argonauts,
stressing the positive economic impact
of creating societies that are open
to diverse peoples, including immigrants.
Usually this group is mostly interested
in highly skilled
immigrants, but not always.
In metropolitan Washington,
South Asian Indians
are the second largest
immigrant group in the region,
probably the only metropolitan area
where they are number two
except maybe San Jose.
They're generally highly educated
and have higher than
average household incomes.
In terms of immigrant settlement,
they are highly suburban and dispersed,
and there's no real residential clusters.
But they are large in number.
Although this map does show
some residential avoidance.
The District of Columbia
and Prince George's County,
which is this area here
that's the palest green.
In both these cases,
these are areas where
African Americans are,
or at least recently
have been, the majority.
The District of Columbia no
longer has a racial majority
as according to 2011 estimates.
For people with families,
the District also has notoriously
underperforming schools,
despite recent efforts to improve them.
So that's one of the explanations.
But mapping immigrant
inclusion or exclusion,
at least in Washington,
there's always a complex layer
of black white racial segregation
that seems to be
influencing the settlement
decisions of immigrant newcomers
from very different backgrounds.
In terms of celebrating
the diversity advantage,
I return to Wheaton,
the location of my imaginary reality show.
Wheaton officials decided
to promote their diversity
with a marketing campaign.
Wheaton, deliciously habit forming.
(audience laughs)
Why go to downtown to eat where the food's
more expensive and there's no parking?
Come to Wheaton, you can still have
all the ethnic food
and diversity you want.
Now my comments about
the cultural landscape.
The cultural landscape
concept has been useful
to me in appreciating the ways
that immigrants change localities.
Not only demographically,
but also through the built environment.
Cultural landscape,
especially residential ones,
often conceal the degree
of social change occurring.
And it epitomizes the lie of the land
that Don Mitchell writes
about in his analysis
of migrant agricultural
workers in California.
But commercial and religious landscapes
can be more revealing of
multicultural dynamism.
There's also an ephemeral
ethnoscapes that groups
create to maintain identity
and transnational linkages.
In terms of immigrant
exclusion or backlash,
these physical changes to familiar places
often deeply distress long-term residents.
So when I take my students out
to Washington's edge gateways,
they are struck by the normalcy of it all.
Narrow townhouses, brick garden apartments
with rows of cars in front of them,
they are in no way
distinct immigrant markers.
They almost seem disappointed.
How come the lawns don't
have pagodas on them?
Or shrines to the Virgin of Guadelupe?
But then we turn a corner and a strip mall
or ethnic shopping center heralds
an immigrant-created landscape
such as Eden Center,
named for a popular shopping
center in former Saigon.
Or Seoul Plaza.
My GW colleague Elizabeth
Chaco defines these
as socio-commerce-scapes
that play an important
commercial and community building roles
for immigrant groups who are
not residentially clustered.
If you've been Washington DC,
you may be familiar with
the Shaw neighborhood,
and especially U Street and 9th Streets,
where there's an impressive array
of Ethiopian restaurants, music
shops, and ethnic services.
Ethiopians were important
small business pioneers
in this area in the 1980s and 90s,
before the Green Line opened up U Street
to a wave of gentrification.
Yet when the Ethiopian community
approached the DC
government about designating
the area Little Ethiopia,
they were publicly rebuked.
For the first half of the 20th century,
U Street in the Shaw neighborhood
was the black Broadway
for segregated Washington.
This is where Duke Ellington
lived and performed
and famous venues such as
the Lincoln Theater are still located.
Ethiopians were welcomed
to bring their businesses
to this place and reshape its landscape
but there was no formal rebranding
of this place as Little Ethiopia.
Ethnoscapes, another Appadurai term,
are created through
fluid networks of people
and are often ephemeral in nature.
Rather than the built environment,
they are an informal
occupation of space for
a particular event that
may be filled with meaning
for the immigrants involved.
I've learned a lot about
the Bolivian community
through spending time at
immigrant-run soccer leagues.
These gatherings are
not just about a sport.
They are social events,
where friends gather,
news from home is
shared, jobs are offered,
and funds are raised to
help communities back home.
One of the more interesting
events I attended
was when the Bolivian ambassador,
the hip guy here in a ponytail,
presented the Copa Evo Morales
to the championship team
from the incopier league Mamanaca.
Here the captain from a very small town,
fewer than 1000 people is accepting
some serious hardware from
the President of Bolivia
in Reston, Virgina.
Which leads to Bolivia,
and how landscape analysis
and interpretation have been fundamental
in understanding the
complex transformation
that is occurring in this rural area
due to long-standing and far-reaching
patterns of immigration.
Up until now, I've focused upon
the impacts of immigration,
but how does emigration
transform landscapes,
and what do people think about this?
An area I have done
research for 10 years now,
the Valle Alto,
this rural scene is very much
a transnationalized landscape.
This rather large church for
a town of maybe 300 people
was built with money from immigrants,
and the plaza in front as well.
All these peach trees are also the result
of capital coming from the US and Spain,
and people investing in the land.
The Valle Alto, thank you Google Earth,
this is the city of Cochabamba,
there's a large dam here,
and this large area here is a high valley
around 9000 feet long,
an important agricultural
center for Bolivia,
and actually, a major
sending area for emigrants
not just within Bolivia
but internationally.
But one of the striking things,
and I visited here and
flown over in a light plane,
is it's, on one level,
it's a very simple place.
Small communities, many
of them were established
three or four hundred years ago.
Humble, poor, and dirt roads,
lots of adobe structures.
But suddenly, there have been
ruptures in the landscape.
And it's been very striking
as people talk about,
this is a house that really stood out
when I was there in, gosh,
it was like 1999.
And it seems to be a competition going on
in these immigrant show houses.
And it led to some very
interesting discussions.
Many of these homes are empty.
People just come for
a few weeks at a time.
Or maybe they have a family
member, or caretaker,
stay in them, and yet the
extraordinary thing is,
every year I go back, there's
more and more of these,
and they are getting
more and more elaborate.
It's not a coincidence
that the immigrants, generally men,
although women immigrate as well,
work in construction,
and they've brought
housing types and designs
that they've done in
places like Barcelona,
or Washington, and they've added it
to the mix of lifestyles.
People have lots of different attitudes.
This man, Juan, said to
me, he grew up in Mamanaca,
spent all his youth in Argentina,
came back with his young children
and then went to the United
States for a few years.
And was, in a quote here, very thankful to
the United States for the opportunity
it gave me to work.
He worked for four
years and then came back
and started building.
Now all of his children
are in the United States.
One recently returned,
and he's been spending
the last few years building
their dream houses.
Not quite as elaborate
as the earlier ones,
but it's a conscious
effort to capitalize abroad
and then build upon a future in Mamanaca
through transnational labor flows.
This is the mayor of Arbieto,
well the former mayor of Arbieto.
He had a pretty downright
negative view of immigration.
He complained that the youth left,
and they were all taking the same road.
Although the road could
lead to different places.
He also complained that the problem
that there's no support, bad governance,
not a progressive state, there's no plan,
we can't do anything.
Interestingly, he was
just voted out of office
about a year ago, and an immigrant
who had made a small fortune
selling used cars in Miami
has returned to Arbieto
and is now running for the town
which locally they refer it
as the land of little gringos
because there's actually
a lot of American-born Bolivians there
and the surrounding
towns and cities complain
as they've got more money than we do.
So this is another rupture in
the socioeconomic landscape.
I'm gonna end with the photo
that always makes me smile.
Employing the concepts
of cultural diffusion
and cultural landscapes when studying
contemporary immigration does not lead
to a Sauerian interpretation of the world.
Yet these concepts can help to explain
why immigration is filled with promise
and negative backlash.
My interest in living with diversity
is very different from Sauer's concern
for conserving diversity.
Or at least preserving the viability
of distinct rural life ways.
The hyper diverse places I've described
are relatively new
sociocultural phenomenon,
but since they're growing and occurring
in many of the global command centers
of the world economy,
making them work is of keen importance.
Sauer's interest in cultural
diffusion was quite specific
in that he saw domesticated
plants and animals
as historically meaningful
cultural products
that diffused widely and in the process
reshaped the biophysical
and cultural landscape.
In terms of human migration,
the early Spanish main by Sauer documents
with devastating precision the impact
of Spanish colonization on
the peoples of Hispaniola.
Conquests, slavery, disease,
and demographic collapse
within 50 years of Spanish arrival.
Consequently for Sauer,
there was no upside
to this migrant-led form
of cultural diffusion
and demographic collapse.
The cultural practices that
immigrants bring with them
are complex, multifaceted
and difficult to pin down.
Yet the cultural anchors
migrants move with
motivate all kinds of
social and economic networks
as well as identity
performances that persist
in interesting and
sometimes unexpected ways
in places of destination.
One way I've tried to
appreciate this cultural malage
is through mapping.
It isn't perfect and perhaps
too empirical for some.
But it is an intuitive
tool that can be used
to elicit process as well as pattern.
Put a street map in front
of a group of people,
immigrants or native-born,
and some sticky dots, and ask them,
where would you like to live, and why?
Or where would you not like to live?
What makes a good neighborhood or
a right place to establish a business?
These simple exercises can reveal starkly
different understandings
of space and place
and culturally diverse settings
where many of us live.
And these can be especially helpful
in working towards greater inclusion.
As for the cultural landscape,
it is a fickle guide to cultural change
with regards to immigration.
That is, it can hide as
much as it can reveal.
Yet I found that paying attention
to the built environment
and the relative visibility
or invisibility of immigrant
communities within it
has opened up ways for understanding
how we live with diversity,
and as we struggle to construct
more inclusive cities.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- [Emcee] We do have
time for some questions
if anybody would like
and we do have a
microphone to pass around.
Anybody wanna ask any questions
or make some comments?
- [Audience Member 1] Great talk, Marie.
I'm wondering with
communities that do aggregate,
if you find another level of aggregation
based on region or ethnicity, for example,
do the Bolivians who are
native Quechuan speakers
tend to live somewhere different from
those who are Spanish or Aymara speakers?
- [Marie] The linguistic isolation's
a really interesting one and you can find,
but in general, I find no,
that actually most of
the speakers who come
are either Spanish or Quechuan speakers
and we don't have many Aymara speakers.
But I mean, if you start
looking at language
and some of the ACS data,
you can tease that out,
but what I've found, the
separation in Bolivians,
and I've mapped this quite a bit,
is that it's often
between class differences
and also time of arrival.
So there's this perception
of the newcomers
versus the old guard, and it's probably
when they are able to buy homes
and afford to live and that shifts.
But you could definitely
move down in scale
in terms of region of origin, language,
and really come up with some
different patterns, I'm sure.
Especially for the Indians,
and I'm still waiting to dig into that.
- [Audience Member 2] I'm curious, Marie,
how important is religious affiliation,
particularly for sort of evangelic
or fundamentalist communities?
- [Marie] You know, I
haven't looked at religion
and I should, but certainly,
Central Americans are
very strongly evangelical
and they often form their own churches
and have very clear transnational linkages
and direct flow so on one level,
you can look at the Catholic Church,
which probably has benefited
enormously from immigration.
Especially Latino, Filipino,
Vietnamese Catholics.
And that is, but there's also,
my colleague Elizabeth
Chaco's worked a lot
on Ethiopians, there's
the Coptic Christians,
and they form their own churches, and so,
while country of origin
is a convenient start
for diversity, you can
slice and dice at religion.
There's a group that have
tried to look at religious
mapping and where churches
are, and synagogues and temples
as a way to understand the complexity.
The thing that always
amazes me in Washington
because we have a large Korean population,
we had huge Korean churches,
and they are very well attended,
so I think like, to get
at the Korean Baptists,
in particular, that's really powerful.
Bolivians, my feeling and experience is,
they don't go to church so much.
They like soccer better.
(audience laughs)
So soccer was clearly the place to go
to learn what was going on.
There's a couple hands back there.
- [Audience Member 3]
Yes thank you. Pardon me.
Thank you very much.
Some time ago, I found a old study,
that I guess now at the
time was quite well known,
was really a confluence study
of the working class communities,
which is a sociological,
rather than anthropological,
or geographical,
at least not self-consciously
either of those.
And he, this was Chicago in the 50s,
so we're talking about all the residue
of Eastern Europeans or Southern Europeans
who are still Eastern European
and Southern European.
And one of the interesting things was,
this was a time of industrial prosperity.
The steel mills were rolling along,
I don't know the exact ups and downs,
economically at the time,
but one of the key places of negotiation
between the different
groups was the workplace,
and sort of large industrial places
with a lot of internal
technical division of labor.
So there's all these fights about
who's going to be the foreman
and who's going to work under whom,
and they, according to Kornblume's
rather rosy picture of it,
is just, you know, burley
guys working it out,
so to speak, and also,
the religious area too,
because there's a mix of, you know,
Orthodoxy and Catholicity,
that is also another place
because there's only so many churches
and you've gotta sort of, once again,
negotiate it in the church.
So I was wondering about,
you know I keep hearing
that in your presentation,
we looked at a lot of residential areas,
and I think in the suburbs
they don't mix it up too much,
but I wanted to know more
about that. Thank you.
- [Marie] Well, two responses.
One of the curious things is,
in the near-in suburbs and the cities,
a lot of churches,
different congregations,
have really lost their,
the base of their congregations.
So what often happens is that
the churches in a sense rent out space,
or appeal to a diversity of immigrants,
and so you might have a congregation
that offers religious services
in seven or eight languages
and the different groups come in.
And so you can have groups
sharing the same space
but coming in at different times.
So how integrative it
is is not, it's limited.
In terms of employment,
some work I've looked at
immigrant entrepreneurship,
in general, immigrants are more likely
to be self-employed than the native-born.
And there's reasons for that,
you know being excluded from the workforce
in some ways and also maybe a desire
to create your own business.
But in the case of Bolivians,
where I've just written a piece
on immigrant entrepreneurship
in Washington,
they had twice a rate of entrepreneurship
than other Hispanics in the area,
and they're really good
at opening a business.
Say, we're gonna do drywall.
Now drywall's not a lot of fun.
(audience laughs)
I don't know if any of
you have done drywall,
they're heavy sheets.
But then they just bring in a stream
of young guys from the country.
There's a boss that organizes it,
there's a lot of trust,
maybe some self-exploitation
amongst co-ethnics,
and they get their drywall
business up and running.
Women have really cornered the market
in these very, kind of
cutesy, domestic services.
One, it's got about 45 Bolivian women,
called Maid in America, M-A-I-D.
Makes me smile.
So they run around in
little Toyota Corollas
and do their cleaning services,
but it's all Bolivian.
Occasionally they'll let in an outsider,
say a Peruvian or Guatemalan,
but it's very interesting how the ethnic,
you know, there is, you know,
as people stay and integrate,
or certainly, by the second
generation or young children,
there's probably a lot
more crossing the lines.
But I think when you first arrive,
there's a real tendency
to stick with your own.
Yes.
- [Audience Member 4] Thanks a lot, Marie,
for bringing us some geographic
concepts to migration
that we don't get enough of, I think.
Couple of questions. One is,
could you tell us a little bit
about when migration kicks off
from the Valle Alto?
What period, what kicks it off?
And then as far as the connections
to the Washington DC area,
what is, what draws the pioneers there?
What is the initial hook there? Thanks.
- [Marie] Great.
So people in the Valle
Alto started migrating
in the 20s, but they weren't
going to North America.
An early movement to Chile
and then also Argentina.
That was clearly the big destination
and it would be much more,
a bus ride to Argentina,
kind of a long bus ride,
and coming back and forth.
Maybe staying there for several years
and then coming back.
I've met some people that
literally call themselves
pioneers that went to the US.
And these first pioneers
came in the 1960s,
late 60s, early 70s,
one of them came as a young woman,
worked as a domestic,
eventually got a college degree,
her daughter went to Harvard,
and now is the only elected
Bolivian official in the US.
She was elected by the
Arlington County school board.
Emma Violand-Sanchez.
And she tells this, you know,
the rags to riches story
that will just make you cry.
She is a believer in what can happen,
these transformations and
opportunities that happen.
But most of the Bolivians
really started coming
in the early 80s and
Bolivia was in terrible
economic free fall, hyper inflation.
And then Argentina wasn't
looking so good either.
So this notion of,
we'd better try someplace new,
somebody knew somebody,
and then the classic
kind of chain migration.
Then very clearly, even before 9/11,
when Operation Gatekeeper
went in in '96, '97,
it got a lot harder,
because many people from the Valle Alto,
they just look at where they're from,
and they're never given a visa.
They just assume they're
intended migrants,
so then they will often come illegally.
And it's very expensive.
$15000, it's a lot of money.
You've gotta work that debt off.
So then the promised land became Spain,
and there are twice as
many Bolivians in Spain now
than in the United States.
And they really poured into
Spain for several years.
And then a few other places.
Italy's got quite a few,
so what's interesting,
you know, unlike the
Mexican immigration story,
it's overwhelmingly to the US,
what is it, 96, 97% of
Mexicans who emigrate
come to the US.
Bolivia's obviously much smaller,
proportionally it has a
very large emigrant stream,
but they've always gone
to a variety of places.
Both within South America and Europe.
There's even an interesting flow to Japan
because Bolivia received
something like 100 Japanese,
you know, when the Brazilian,
mostly they were going to Brazil,
and then if you could
somehow prove ancestry,
you can get to Japan.
So the embassy estimates there's
like 2000 Bolivian Japanese,
we say that with
quotation marks, in Japan,
because they're probably
not ethnically Japanese
but they somehow proved that.
So that strategy, and I think right now,
there's, the flows are not,
illegal flows are very small,
because it's so hard and expensive.
And there's also been a pretty
significant deportation.
I was looking at some statistics
and the Obama administration has deported
more people than any other President,
any other presidential administration,
still got another year to go.
I don't think that was
totally intentional.
It was about the changes
in secure communities
but we're not just talking
stopping people at the borders,
these are deportations of people
who've lived several years.
And it's wrenching.
I've been to fundraisers when
you know, basically what happens,
dad drives to work, dad gets stopped,
dad doesn't have a driver's license
because you can't get one
if you're undocumented.
Dad is arrested.
Dad's detained for months
and the family's stuck.
Kids might be Americans
so that deportation story is obviously
a kind of a national deflection strategy.
But it's plays out all the
time in the Latino media.
We don't hear it as
much in the Anglo media.
But estimates are that one
in four Latinos in the US
know someone who has
been deported or will be.
And that's a really sad figure but it's,
it plays up at least in the work
I've been doing in Washington,
how immigrants perceive
their opportunities.
I think it merely means
the economic challenges
with the recession is just,
coming here is not so appealing.
Greg?
Use the microphone.
(audience member mumbles)
This is also my brother.
(audience laughs)
- [Marie's Brother] So I was looking
at the economic examples,
the economic examples from
Prince William County,
two questions.
How well known in that
community were those
in the economic consequences
of the immigration policy.
And looking at what's happening in Alabama
and earlier in Arizona,
what could our elected officials
learn from geographers?
- [Marie] Hmm.
(audience laughs)
Thank you for that policy question.
So in Prince William County,
and as people have looked at the data,
it's very hard to tease out
the impacts of the recession,
which was coming on at the same time.
But and there was also a lot
of home foreclosures there,
especially among Hispanics,
and was that because they
just decided to walk away
because of the political environment?
The political environment was really ugly.
And I went to a couple meetings
and it was terrifying.
It really had this mob quality of people
just inciting, saying outrageous things,
from both sides.
So one of the things
that I learned from that.
I went and interviewed the sheriff,
who had to enforce those.
And I asked him, you know,
let's say, tomorrow
legislation was changed
and everybody that came undocumented,
which was the target of
their search, became legal,
what would that mean to you?
And he said, it would make
my life so much easier.
This is a really hard thing to do.
We can't police this way.
And to me, the lesson from Prince Williams
was that it, again it often happens,
it was really one or two politicians
that saw an opportunity to play on fears
and prejudices and run with it.
So that is one lesson.
In terms of Alabama, I don't get it.
It's not like Alabama has a lot
of immigrants to begin with,
but I do think it plays
upon a general feeling
of all immigration is somehow
tainted with illegality now
because of the, the deadlock we're in.
You know, there has been,
people have been saying
immigration reform is coming,
it's coming, it's coming,
it's not coming.
And so, states and jurisdictions think,
well, this is the way we act,
and I'm not sure Alabama can
go much lower economically,
so that's you know, hard to
really, you know, compete.
But Arizona, I think there is some pretty
convincing evidence that it's
having economic implications
but at the same time,
you know, if you really
believe that immigration
is making your place worse,
then you're gonna need to martial evidence
that will support that, and people do.
- [Emcee] I think that was probably,
unless somebody has
another burning question,
it's probably the last question,
what can geographers offer
to politics in a good way,
for us to all reflect on,
and also think about the ways in which
Marie has so creatively used some of these
Sauerian concepts to engage us
in something of everyday concern.
We thank you enormously.
Please join us for refreshments
just in the atrium here,
and thanks again, Marie.
(audience applauds)
- [Marie] Thank you.
(gentle music)